[Music]
started on the 2nd the second
has completely lost the rudder, they have
broken the kodaste the limera and they have
caused damage to the hull which is
structural
[Music]
it is clear that you will see that the last
three years have  There were more than 600
attacks on sailboats, it was not known
exactly, but we see
more and more individuals that are part of
this aggression against
sailboats
[Music] it
is not something generalized for the
population of orcas in the strait, it seems to
be related  with certain
families to think that in reality
orcas are animals that are
familiar, they are groups that are very
intelligent and that they have an element of
oral transmission of knowledge
cannot be related to that
[Music]
we are working with various
hypotheses from games to  any
type of attack there is a version
[Music]